[Music]
Chris Hogan here I've spent so much time
on the road and talked with a lot of
people and the millionaire success
stories that I run into might surprise
you whether I'm at an event or talking
on my podcast one thing has become clear
most people have no idea what a
self-made millionaire really looks like
you're going to get a glimpse into the
life of a self-made millionaire
these folks are hard at work you don't
want to miss it people this is
millionaire we're going to start off
with Larry in Medford Oregon hey Larry
how are you hey I'm doing great better
than I imagined I love it so what's your
net worth sir well we're actually
closing in our four billion today right
at four million good for you my name's
Larry from Southern Oregon
my wife Dee I'm a graphic design
advertising executive after about a
thirty year career it was time to kind
of scale back a little bit and I've
always been in the print industry so I
started out working for my father later
went into sales so I've been in sales
for about thirty years and I'm still
working I started at San Diego State and
then transferred to Art Center College
of Design and got my bachelor of fine
arts there started in Del mark as a art
director my starting salary at that time
was twenty one thousand years
which is about $11 an hour and you you
were probably that same 8,000 remember
and then it is slowly built and worked
up to you know how 2,000 in the end and
there were some spikes in there you had
some big job years where a lot of things
happen to come through in that one year
and we started making enough money that
we could actually afford some nicer
things in life but we are still playing
that game of you know credit cards and
having a lot of debt building up and
getting a car loan and that sort of
thing like everyone else does I agree
that we were not particularly focused on
any goal when we first started out it
was basically you know probably like
everyone else we weren't making huge
sums of money and we were living
paycheck to paycheck but as time went by
we started realizing that our pay were
working really hard but yet the money
just kind of staying flat and my parents
had taught me early on they were
successful in their careers and started
getting involved in real estate that
there's something greater that we wanted
to become and you know how I can't just
be in the squirrel wheel forever so we
started thinking about plans and making
some adjustments probably my first
awareness of trying to save for
retirement came through company offering
401k I researched that realized that it
seemed like a good way to start
investing it's like you know did what I
could every year to fill that up and
then you know he ended up with something
similar buying the advertising business
that had been around for 35 years and
very successful I took on that that task
of being the president and creative
director started a 401k for everyone
that worked for me and so that kind of
started get my interest doing the
research on how to set this up for a
company now starts to you know bring
that home to me like oh well this is a
real thing we had a little bit extra
money and just started putting that away
but I kind of compared to the the
tortoise and the hare that we weren't
like so we're habit about what we need
all this money and we need to need work
work work and you know worked 18 hours a
day and this sort of thing I think if
you're after a quick fix and quick
success I think leads to more
disappointment because that's such a
very chance of being that battle even
NASA I think if you can get into
mentality of building slowly quickly it
will look behind you'll see you actually
are progressing and so just give it time
in time it's in your favor when you're
young you know if you follow the math
and you know 10% interest will double
your investment every 10 years it just
kind of happens you know if you don't
you know fall on your face too many
times you keep picking yourself up and
learning from any mistakes that you make
but over the time 3040 years you'll be
quite successful if you just stay stay
the path and be true to yourself and it
will come well one of the benefits of
waiting and saving and getting to the
point where you're actually able to
change your life for us we wanted to
break out of our routine that we had do
something different and we were able to
relocate to this home which we've really
fallen in love with and we have the
Rogue River right outside our window and
a gigantic 200 year old redwood tree
also that we enjoy you know it's a
really wonderful opportunity for us to
do something pretty amazing I'm a big
opportunist when it comes to you know
doors opening where you aren't afraid to
walk through that threshold the
interesting aspect of our lives is that
we've always been curious about doing a
lot of different things so I see that as
just a really fun goal for the future -
it's like what else is coming up that we
can do and be interested in yeah I would
say the key to success is tenacity and
just going for what can better yourself
and in turn that are other people I grew
up wanted to be an artist I mean it's
possibility for everyone
we lived in a kind of remote area of San
Diego County and surrounded by trees and
brush well there's a huge fire that came
to town from a short short and an
electric line and really high winds
coming from the east and we basically
had to escape our house in the middle of
flames and really barely made it out
houses were burning we can see where we
were going and then I get to that
leading edge of the orange flame cap
stop so I actually had to drive into the
fire and the police were signaling us
through I think we probably surprised in
a our cars coming out of there and we
all hugged each other and taught how it
is living through that experience you
know you don't you're never satisfied
with where you are you're always pushing
and you always wanted to be something
better and just like escaping the fire
and the success of living and to have
another day you don't just stop and wait
and burn keep moving forward I think
would be a key and funny success
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]